[Music]
on this Saturday night China's new
coveted surge that will soon test Canada
Millions travel while new variants
spread the new concerns overseas and the
ripple effect here
a travel nightmare ends for some
Canadians in Mexico plus what El Chapo's
son's arrest means for the drug trade in
Canada
the U.S House of Representatives finally
picks a speaker the humiliating 15th
ballot Victory I never give up the
dramatic moments getting there and who
the new house Speaker credits for the
win
that's my dad and a trip to the art
gallery unlike any other
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us this holiday season we saw hundreds
of thousands of Canadians travel to be
with family and friends in China the
biggest travel season kicks off today
with the Lunar New Year there the number
of Travelers are in the billions and
bringing with them a new wave of
covid-19 concerns though some are taking
their own precautions this will be the
first Lunar New Year without any
domestic travel restrictions since the
start of the pandemic leading to a
travel Rush which threatens to inflame
the country's already raging outbreak
Canada is one of more than a dozen
countries now testing travelers from
China but as Sharia Israel reports it
might not make a difference
millions of people in China have started
crisscrossing the country for the Lunar
New Year
from train rides to flights and bus
rides an estimated 2 billion trips will
be made over the holiday
and as commuters move around so will
covid-19 this this is the concern in
China is that the lunar year is going to
spread infection to the whole of China
and therefore the worst is still to come
a mass Exodus is underway from cities to
the countryside with passengers
desperate to see family after years of
separation under strict lockdowns my
grandparents have also told me many
times that they miss me a lot but in
rural China vaccination rates are low
and Health Care is limited
we've enhanced training for medical
workers in these areas says China's
national Health commission but hospitals
in urban centers are already struggling
to cope with the surge infections have
soared since the country abruptly ended
its covet zero policy the World Health
Organization warns Beijing as Under
reporting cases the tragedy of a
government that wants to
to consider itself infallible so you're
not allowed to admit your mistakes
a growing list of countries including
Canada now require passengers from China
to show negative covid tests but Health
experts believe it will make little
difference you
know but you will never stop
virus or the bacteria when it's out of
the bottle
it is just too many ports of Entry in
Europe and North America an offshoot of
Omicron is circulating sub-variant xbb15
is spreading rapidly in the U.S now
making up 70 percent of new infections
in the Northeast there are a few dozen
confirmed cases in Canada but with the
lack of testing that number is likely
higher doctors say it's the most
transmissible strain yet but does not
appear more severe we are fortunate in
that we have a reasonably good firewall
of high levels of vaccination
including now booster doses although
they're still lagging
and getting vaccinated is the best layer
of protection as the virus keeps
evolving Toria Israeli Global News
Ottawa
some Canadian tourists in Mexico's
Sinaloa state are checking out of their
hotels and returning home after a wave
of violence erupted this week shuttering
airports and prompting an advisory to
shelter in place
19 suspected gang members and 10
military personnel were killed following
the arrest of Mexican drug cartel boss
ovidio Guzman the son of notorious drug
lord El Chapo two airports in the region
have reopened with flights back to
Canada scheduled today
joining me now is Reuters senior
correspondent David Graham who's worked
in Mexico for the past decade David
thanks so much for joining us let's
start with the latest on the situation
on the ground right now
things are gradually returning to normal
up in Sinaloa but there's an enhanced
military presence obviously because sir
they're trying to keep things as under
you know control as possible the airport
is reopening has reopened and you know
to the best of our understanding things
are arguing back to normal but clearly
the people there are pretty shocked at
what's been going on what's the latest
with Guzman himself
uh he is in in detention he's being held
held in the same Maximum Security Prison
west of Mexico City um away his father
is
uh in 2015 and of course all the pending
um question of his extradition is is
being considered now and of course will
be no doubt the subject too much
comments in the day of the head
it's a high profile arrest is obviously
a win for Mexico and for the U.S but is
it really going to make a difference in
terms of drug trafficking in North
America
I think right that will depend on what
they do next because clearly you know
you get uh publicity for uh capturing
someone who is very high profile but I
think if no steps are taking to really
dry up the sources of revenue to go
after the structures of these
organizations then you know I think
people will be skeptical about how much
can be done to really uh hold the supply
of drugs
how will what we've seen this week David
impact how Mexico is seen on the world
stage I mean we know it's a popular
tourist destination but also
geopolitically
well I mean obviously while you have the
good news of uh from the government's
perspective of capturing a high profile
Target you also have the images of the
scenes result where you can and the
violence and so you know I think it will
tend to perhaps Harden some of the
perceptions that Mexico has
to live with that it is a place where
um these kind of incidents do occur so I
think you know I think we can come as it
is is not really a major tourist
destination but it is a big city and you
know I think it will in that sense just
remind people of what Mexico perhaps has
been a fairly or unfairly famous for in
the last few years
Canada's prime minister is going to be
where you are right now David Mexico
City in three days for a summit of North
American leaders so do these events
change what the three leaders are going
to be discussing
I mean the Americans have already said
that they would like to discuss fentanyl
uh during the talks next week and this
is of course a synthetic opioid that's
been blamed for a number of deaths in an
increasing number of deaths in the U.S
and I think also in Canada has been you
know an issue so I think it will be
prominent because of the circumstances
of the capture the arrest security is
also going to be discussed correct
and what we discussed because it's a
it's a it's a it's a permanent topic
because it approaches excuse me not only
the issue of um drug trafficking but
also the border and immigration is is
always a big deal when it comes to
Mexico and the US and so that will
definitely be on the agenda when they
when they get down to business next week
Reuters senior correspondent David Grant
thanks so much for your time and your
Insight
in Saskatchewan a family is calling for
systemic change in health care after
losing a loved one to a drug overdose
Shane Turner died just hours after he
was discharged from a Regina hospital
it's a tragic loss his family believes
could have been avoided as advocates say
similar patients are being failed by
hospitals across the country Conor
O'Donovan reports
we felt defeated it feels like it's just
another person of power and authority
that is dismissing the addiction crisis
in our Province on November 8 2021 Shane
Turner was discharged from Regina
General Hospital after being treated for
an overdose just hours later he was
found dead after overdosing again on
fentanyl this week the coroner denied
his family's call for an inquest instead
issuing a recommendation that a
Saskatchewan health authority improved
coordination between hospitals and Detox
Services but with more people dying of
overdose in the province than ever
before and detox centers often full
Turner's family says opportunities need
to be identified to capitalize on time
spent in care in Saskatchewan it's a
people of partner Authority that have
the advantage in changing the narrative
for the addiction crisis in the province
and are refusing to do so others say
more needs to be done across the country
Health Canada says in the first half of
2022 there were over 2 500 opioid
related hospital visits across the
country and while file data on post-care
outcomes is sparse one 2019 study in the
UK found that fatal opioid overdoses
were four times more likely to occur in
the first two days after discharged than
at other times this BC based Advocate
says hospitals around Canada need to do
a better job of ensuring the safety of
those who come and go through their
doors dropped off onto the sidewalk or
kicked out at 3am with a bus ticket
nowhere to go I mean you know it doesn't
make it feel like you want to go back
there and get any support after battling
addiction for years guy fellichella says
he's witnessed dramatic improvements at
St Paul's Hospital in Vancouver which
has piloted programs giving overdose
patients take-home Suboxone kits
designed to stop cravings and prevent
fatal overdoses the hospital has also
operated a safe consumption site
felicella adds that patients could
benefit from 24 7 in-hospital access to
peer recovery coaches it works well here
for sure and I think it could work well
and if it's mimic across the provinces
uh in Canada right now cello says
programs like these are few and far
between Canada leaving patients at risk
the same way Shane Turner was SP
ice preventable Conor O'Donovan Global
News Regina
the U.S finally has a house Speaker
after Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
was voted in following a historic 15th
ballot but the bruising battle and the
promises made is leaving questions about
how Congress will function Jennifer
Johnson reports
Kevin McCarthy of the State of
California has received 216.
after four days 15 votes and a week
filled with quarreling and Chaos
Congress has elected its new house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy had to flip more
than a dozen conservatives to get the
votes he needed if there's one thing I
want the country to hopefully learned
about me this week is that I will never
give up Americans haven't seen such
disarray in this proceeding in over a
hundred years at one point tensions were
so high a fight almost broke out between
GOP lawmakers Mike Rogers and Matt Gates
who led the battle against McCarthy
McCarthy was forced to broker a deal
which weakens his own power allowing a
single member to call a vote to oust him
from Office Democrats say McCarthy
promised way too much to extremist
Republicans prompting this tongue
lashing from the House minority leader
on what his party wants reason over
racism substance over slander triumph
over tyranny understanding over ugliness
to get the votes he needed McCarthy
agreed to give conservatives more power
on house committees including one to
investigate the quote weaponization of
the federal government as Donald Trump
calls his ongoing investigations by the
FBI and Department of Justice McCarthy
gained the speakership and made it clear
who helped him to Victory I do want to
especially thank president Trump
I don't think you should anybody should
doubt his influence
he was with me from the beginning the
ultra conservatives also want more
investigations into President Joe Biden
his son Hunter greater border security
abortions restrictions cuts to some
federal employees salaries and possibly
Social Security and Medicare they told
the American people they wanted to win
the majority to fight inflation the only
thing they're fighting is each other
this kind of fighting and a divided
congress with Democrats still
controlling the Senate has Global
Watchers on high alert with everything
from Ukraine war funds to trade with
Canada America's closest Ally at risk
House Republicans are promising Unity
but Democrats and the president have
their doubts Jennifer Johnson Global
News Washington
to the latest in the war despite a
declaration of a ceasefire from Moscow
for Eastern Orthodox Christmas shelling
continues today in Ukraine
Russian President Vladimir Putin
committed to a 36-hour ceasefire for
forces in Ukraine and said troops only
returned fire when shot at by Ukrainian
forces Ukrainian president vlodimir
zielinski said the attacks showed Moscow
could not be trusted Ukrainian officials
also called the ceasefire a ploy for
Russia to rest its forces and give them
time to rearm after a week of heavy
losses on its side
Canadian politics and the planet coming
up the province that feels it's greener
than the rest and its influence on
Ottawa
new internal government polling obtained
by global news is underlining how Keen
the people of Quebec are to see Ottawa
take more action on climate change
according to the data it's a stance more
popular there than in any other Province
and as David Aiken reports since the
federal liberals have heavily relied on
Quebec support to win the last three
elections that Zeal for all things green
is almost certain to influence the
Trudeau government's agenda David Aiken
now joins us from Ottawa David
before this data is from the privy
Council offices weekly polling program
now it's from the summer but was only
recently released to us through an
access to information request and this
data shows quebecers easily think of
themselves as Canada's greenest Province
one poll question asked should Ottawa
focus more or Focus Less on climate
change in the rest of Canada 48 percent
said more 25 percent said less but in
Quebec a whopping 71 percent said more
just seven and a half percent said less
when asked to choose between lowering
gas prices or fighting climate change a
majority in the rest of Canada 54
percent said cut gas prices but in
Quebec nearly two-thirds 61 percent said
no fight climate change and when asked
if inflation or climate change should be
the higher priority for Ottawa the
pattern held again in the rest of Canada
41 said inflation but in Quebec a clear
majority 56 percent picked climate
change I think Quebec nationalism in a
way now sees itself as being green or
the idea that Quebec is greener than
other provinces has now become part of
provincial identity the Liberals hold 35
seats in Quebec and if they hope to
repeat winning a minority government at
least they must be seen to be aggressive
on the issue most important to quebecers
climate policy the Liberals are
approaching the environment uh uh in
Quebec knowing that it's it's it's very
important for quebecers on average more
than four people in other provinces and
that means Quebec has an outsized
influence on how the Trudeau government
designs climate policies for the entire
country well I try to explain to people
here that it's the reason that they take
into account Quebec more than let's say
Alberta is not just the seat count it's
that they change parties it's a
four-party system now Quebec Zeal for
the environment is also a challenge for
the opposition conservatives if they
hope to win a larger share of Quebec's
75 seats Farah all right that is our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken in Ottawa thanks David
Canada's missing and murdered indigenous
women and girls ahead and met leaders
calls for action on the tragedies that
aren't going away
as we begin a new year we take a look at
a major issue in Canada that was once
again brought to the Forefront last
December our country's missing and
murdered indigenous women and girls West
block hosts Mercedes Stevenson sat down
with Cassidy Caron metis National
Council president to talk about this and
the other issues her communities are
facing
Cassidy I was really struck watching the
tragedy unfolding in Winnipeg of the
state that we still face for indigenous
women in this country and the attention
that that their family members and
daughters were able to bring by being so
strong and so articulate may make the
difference there but there are many many
more women who are Vanishing and who
have died and have been murdered and and
it just sort of goes as a blip on the
radar and as long as I've been in Ottawa
people have been talking about this
issue
why do you think it is that it feels
like we're on a treadmill with it and
and there's commitment after commitment
at various levels of government uh but
then we continue to see it be this
incredible tragedy for indigenous
Canadians and for all Canadians that
this is happening
such a massive issue that permeates
every corner of our society and I think
that because it is such a massive issue
it paralyzes so many people they don't
know what to do but you're absolutely
right people have been talking about
this crisis that we face in Canada for
years now and it's so unfair to family
members to continue to have to go to the
media and tell their stories over and
over again for it only to pick up steam
for a couple of weeks maybe a month and
then for it to drop off until again it
becomes a big news story we've seen this
happen time and time again in Canada
where indigenous people are telling
their stories they're telling their
truths you know with the Royal
Commission on Aboriginal people The
Truth and Reconciliation Commission the
inquiry into missing and murdered
indigenous women and girls and even most
recently as a senate report on the
forced sterilization of indigenous women
and girls
people are telling their stories and
it's time for Canadians it's time for
politicians at all levels to listen and
to really dedicate the time the
resources and just the care to create
the change so that we can move forward
in a good way
you can catch a Mercedes full interview
with Cassidy Caron tomorrow on the west
block right here on global foreign
Discovery decades in the making next the
amazing coincidence that reunited a
Toronto woman with a cherished
photograph
[Music]
during a visit to the Art Gallery of
Ontario a woman noticed someone very
familiar in an exhibit her father as
Brittany Rosen reports the discovery was
not only a surprise to her but also to
her dad
not long after Jeanette Robinson Daley
stepped foot into this exhibit at the
Art Gallery of Ontario just a half hour
before they closed She was drawn to a
very familiar face asked my dad in a sea
of photos on display there was her
father Prince Robinson there was a
couple young people here in Millennials
around and I was like hey this is my dad
they're just like okay whatever but at
that time that meant so much to me this
is the old apartment Robinson Daly says
she recognized everything in the photo
taken by her mother more than 50 years
ago from the apartment near Christy
Pitts Park to the man holding the
trumpet she immediately called her dad I
said I saw your picture and the art
gallery and he's like what I said yes
you you're holding a trumpet and he was
he said tears came to his eyes at that
time it's
befota was found somewhere in California
and to this day Prince still has the
Polaroid camera that captured it the
once forgotten moment now being
displayed in the ago's what matters most
exhibit which highlights everyday
moments of black family life the
creators of this exhibit went through
thousands of photos that were lost all
over North America and then found they
then selected the 500 that are on these
walls and given the circumstances of
their Discovery they say it is extremely
unlikely that someone would be able to
recognize someone they know let alone a
family member finding the photograph of
her father Prince Robinson on the wall
it's like a needle in a haystack it
feels it was such a surprise
and more than just a full circle moment
Robinson Daley says the experience has
strengthened this father-daughter Bond
some things money can never buy and this
is one of those things Brittany Rosen
Global News
what a find and that's global national
for this Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser
and on behalf of our whole crew I want
to thank you so much for spending part
of your evening with us tonight's York
Canada is this plane's bison at Elk
Island National Park in Fort
Saskatchewan Alberta we love seeing your
Canada so please keep emailing us your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]